[Music]
anime is usually a medium where amazing
happens it's a brand of escapism often
featuring ordinary humans finding out
that they've got amazing powers or that
they have some transcendental purpose in
life as a chosen one one common way that
the writers set that kind of plot thread
up is by making the characters more than
just human being an ordinary guys not so
amazing but how about becoming a half
angel a half God or something half like
that that my friends is what today's
video is about in this list we take a
look at ten characters who we find out
aren't so human after all
as if the attack on titan comparisons
weren't enough Seraph of the end another
witch studio show that features
humanity's fight for survival against
monsters stars Yuichiro yeah Kuya one of
the children who survived the initial
cleansing that released the floodgates
to the vampire reign over the world so
just like attack on Titan we have an
angry kid who swears to kill all of the
insert enemy species here as our hero in
contrast Yui ends up not being a vampire
at least he doesn't become what he swore
to exterminate right as fate would have
it you he ends up becoming a half Seraph
yes a seraph a powerful angel of
judgment in his first transformed form
Yui relentlessly attacks everyone
displaying no interest in vampires and
showing the powerful latent powers
within him in a way it reminds me of
someone else that we'll be seeing later
on this list who knew that the titular
Seraph of the end would be our main
character all along
beyond the boundaries main protagonist
Akihito Cannavaro is a next entry by
virtue of being half your move you know
one of those creatures that comes in all
shapes that can possess humans at first
glance you wouldn't really think of a
kahin toe as someone unique and
spectacular that is until you remember
that he's someone very knowledgeable
about the spirit world all that starts
making sense once you remember that
Akihiko is half yo mu in a literal sense
born from the union of a human mother
and a young mu father he has the ability
to manipulate fire and power to self
regenerate accompanying Mirai on her
quest to slave violin yo mu he uses his
powers to great effect little does he
know that is not just any kind of half
your moon perhaps he does possess
something even greater something even
stronger than his stock your more powers
within him as to what that is though
you'll just have to watch this
underrated gem from qne to find out
we've known a lot of hybrids in anime
but how does being the son of the
literal devil sound that's just what
blue exorcist protagonists Rin is sewing
off is your typical anime delinquent rin
finds his life changed when he runs into
a demon and awakens his powers in the
form of blue flames turns out that he's
not human all along and is a human demon
hybrid it goes one step further than
most anime would do however he's not
just a regular hybrid but the son of
Satan himself after another incident
involving father Shiro Fujimoto rin
finds himself caught up in the grand
scheme of things as a member of the true
cross order now the devil son has become
the greatest thorn in his side will rin
get stronger and complete his quest to
defeat his father well you might want to
read both the manga and watch the anime
for this series things deviate quite a
lot between the two versions 7 is Claire
from Claymore the Claymore universe is
no stranger to hybrids in fact the
heroes are a sect of hybrids the
Claymore warriors are actually half
human and half Yama and their job is to
hunt their kin for your mom who prey on
helpless humans however things are a bit
different in Claymore because our main
characters become the state that they're
in by having you and my flesh implanted
in them the main character Claire takes
things a bit further by having herself
implanted with Claymore flesh instead
that makes her quarter yuma and while it
comes with the price of having week of
physical abilities it does come with a
really important ability due to her
status as merely a quarter yuma claire
has far greater control of her powers
and considering what happens to fallen
Claymore warriors this comes really
handy in a pinch
it's time to feature one of Zoomers many
choices for their first wife who has the
sixth entry to the list and I can see
why she's not really my favorite
character in darling in the Franks but
there are lots of things to like about
0-2 and they're not have you guys found
it endearing due to her appearance in a
strong personality but 0 2 is actually a
character with a lot of hidden depths
just as we found out whilst watching the
series however one notable thing about
her is that she's part crack source or
somehow I mean her appearance is already
kind of a giveaway that there's
something beyond her reputation as a
partner killer or some of her quirks
turns out that her clacks a source ID
comes as a result of being a clone of
the clacks assault princess or so she's
unable to reproduce thus making her
truly a one-of-a-kind hybrid in the
darling in the Franks universe
good old aaron from attack on titan at
this point who's really surprised to see
him on this list give an attack on
titans popularity and how he's probably
the most intensed among the possible
candidates driven by pure rage and
vengeance eren's Titan form perfectly
encapsulates the turmoil within him with
the exception of the Colossus Titan
Aaron's probably the most iconic and
recognizable Titan the series has to
offer it seems all too cruel that the
poor boy who swore vengeance against
these monsters would end up being turned
into one himself but as long as it
grants him the power to clean house on
fellow monsters we all know that Aaron
would take the opportunity with pleasure
nothing would be sweeter than putting an
end to the Titan menace using their own
powers against them man what's with
these äôt light shows popping up all of
a sudden Seraph of the end the actual
attack on titan and now Carbonari of the
iron fortress makes him seem even more
similar to one another when you look at
it this way doesn't it anyway coming up
next is mume a mysterious govern airy
girl whose encounter with a coma kicks
off the real meat of Carbonari of the
iron fortresses plot introduced as a
carbon Airy gift girl traveling through
Aragon a with her brother circumstances
force her to join the crew after the
loss of a handler mume is unique for a
half Carbonari in a sense that she
became one through a different means
instead of being bitten by one of those
zombies standings and becoming one
herself mu mates hybridization came
through surgical means turns out a blood
injection could do the trick as well
granting her all those enhanced
abilities that proved useful in the
fight against the carbon Ares an
invaluable ally during these times of
need indeed
with how big Tokyo ghoul was some years
ago I'd be surprised if none of you guys
expected connect you to be here
Carnegie's introduction into the world
of ghouls is not a nice one to say the
least after having a lethal encounter in
a date gone horribly wrong and being
saved by pure luck Carnegie discovers
his disdain that he's become one of
those flesh-eating monsters that
traumatized him so much it's good for
him that he'd soon encounter not so
hostile ghouls and have a slightly
smoother transition into his new society
however it takes a long while before he
finally comes to terms and accepts what
he's become when he does world watch out
Carnegie proves to be an interesting
case for me as much of his growth and
on-screen development comes from his
road to accepting the ghoul side of him
in fact his crowning moment in the first
season comes when he finally gives in
and unleashes his power on that
copyright infringement of a villain
what a couple of weeks has been for
Ichigo we all thought that bleach was
pretty much done as an anime for the
longest time but we just got the news
that the anime will be returning in its
full glory fans of anime in the 2000s
will remember it should go as the tough
guy who can see ghosts and ends up
becoming a Shinigami his most iconic
moments including being pierced by Rukia
sword and gaining said Shinigami powers
as well as donning the all too
recognizable mask and letting his hollow
side take over it wouldn't be fair to
call it ego half human at this point
given the number of species in the
Bleach verse he is for the longest time
Ichigo has become shonan's poster child
for a character who just becomes
everything a running joke has it that
ego is a hybrid of everything in the
series he started out a human then got
Shinigami and hollow powers who knows
how much higher he can go when it comes
to being the master of everything don't
tell me that he's also a Quincy all
along wait a minute
[Music]
ironically our top character on this
edition of the list is from a series not
too different from the second place up
in fact bleach was inspired by yu yu
hakusho if my memory serves me right
either way we have us gay or a mushy
half human half demon topping this list
Yusuke is an interesting variation of
the character type when compared to
Ichigo first of all he's not a
combination of so many different species
like you to go second and more
importantly he's technically not a
hybrid on first look both of his parents
are human but several generations back
his ancestor is Rison one of the three
kings and the demon world's most
powerful demon this explains his powers
his transformations and the form that
manifests during the battle against sin
sweep I just knew that something was up
when he busted out that overpowered form
and beat the hell out of sense we his
demon heritage goes a long way back and
I wonder how many of you guys called it
at the start of the series hey how many
of you knew that something like that
would be revealed eventually I've got to
ask you now which one of these amongst
the top ten did you like the most is
there anyone else that I missed out that
you felt deserved to be included in this
list if so I'd love to hear your
opinions the comment section is there
and you know the drill
as an aside if there's also something
that you want me to do as a top 10 list
write it down and let's see what I can
do thanks for the support and I hope to
see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]